good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Friday hope
everybody is having a great day as we
head into the weekend hello jacalene
jacn fle Jac fle how are you hi Claudia
I am okay at this very moment because
right before we started recording just
now I was happened upon our talk shop
live live stream from Wednesday night I
never like thought about it again after
we recorded it
and so I just started to watch a few
minutes just to see like what the [__]
did we do on there it's all a haze per
usual it was so buoying and cute and
then I went right from that to start
recording with you so it kind of put me
in a better mood than I would have been
in okay that's good that's good uh this
episode is podcast only Jackie and I are
both um not in the studio today so if
you're looking for the YouTube
video you'll be looking for a while
you'll be looking till Monday you'll be
looking till Monday and we are going to
just you know dive in do the stues do
our best to remain booing forces in this
ever chaotic and disappointing world yes
but it is more important than ever that
we have things in which to buoy ush
what's booing you like in the last 24
hours that's a great
question that's a great question I have
haven't really gotten into any watching
anything maybe because I'm not like at
home with my TV so it would just be a
production to have to turn something on
so I haven't watched anything other than
my phone um but I look forward to
actually one of our stories today is a
piece of content that I hope to find
booing it's a new show coming out okay
do you w to give no I don't want nope
because then we'll talk about it because
we both are going to feel strongly about
it and like I just want to say it for
the stories cuz the stories need like
all the meat that they can get got it
okay no that's fair like it's becoming
increasingly difficult to find topics
talk to talk about yeah but but we did
it we did it we did it uh what's booing
you not much yeah not much you you yeah
you know my people you are booing me
ja my people are booing being me and
tury Lou is one of my peeps and what
about chy L always of course she doesn't
have that edge that tury has yeah so
would you say tury greater than Trudy
yes I would no offense to Trudy I've
just known tury longer yeah no that's
fair would you say
that definitely I I I don't really
associate myself with
Trudy I really don't I don't know her I
don't
feel like ident I don't identify with
her no she's kind of like a case of
mistake in
identity yeah no and like tury becomes
me Trudy like tried Trudy was trying too
hard do you know what I mean sad for try
sad for Trudy L but not sad for tury l
no tury kills
it without question without question so
we're here to booy you into the weekend
I hope you know everyone has some lovely
weekend plans to buoy themselves I look
forward to the weekend this has
obviously been an incredibly hard
week period lot going on so just you
know also working through it like you
know doing the show and all of that like
it's just a lot so I'm I'm looking
forward to like a few days off to just
reflect and and not have to talk all the
time agreed like I think like you said
processing what happened to like our
people is is honestly like a form of
trauma and then having to like talk
through those feelings publicly is very
scary
because you know it's like a vulnerable
thing and then of course and then you
have everyone giving their thoughts on
your thoughts like I don't care I'm just
exper I'm experiencing my own thing
right now and we're like I'm we're all
just doing our best so like any sort of
commentary I'm not interested in but it
is the job um and I do feel like like
you said like it's an important role um
but I'd be lying if I didn't say like it
was extremely challenging to get up and
do the show every day this week like
every day was harder than the next yeah
and every day was like a different range
of emotions but I I did feel like
throughout the week I felt more
determined to do it when I saw you know
how much positive feedback we were
getting from people who like really
needed episodes that that could wait
into light-heartedness but also
acknowledge what happened like I I feel
proud of of what we're doing um but
we're also we're just human you know and
we're doing our best and the thing is I
think people forget as much as like we
our show is amazing and we crush it like
we're not trained journalists like we're
not professionals like we're just like
girls like we're just girls we're just
girls who are just trying our best on
our best [__] rocks I completely
agree we don't have like you know s like
the training for you know on the ground
report like this sort of thing we're
just emo girls yeah no we're just girls
like who are deeply deeply proud of Our
Heritage
and our heritage is the exact and like
our people are the exact thing that's
like being it's like Up For Debate right
now yeah and it's been it's been
traumatizing like seriously like having
to explain and defend myself
um but unfortunately it's also like
extremely important because it's it's
not registering for a lot of people no
and for us it's like the only thing that
matters whether or not our people have a
right to exist like right everything
else sort of Falls by the wayside side
literally everything else Falls by the
wayside and if it weren't for just like
this insane determination
to get involved and and speak on behalf
of the people who can't speak on behalf
of themselves then like we wouldn't be
doing the show this week I would have
taken this week off but it's not an
option no it's not an option and when
you think about it it's like no the we
have to go on we we have to live like
life can't stop that's exactly what they
want like we have to forge ahead no
matter how hard it is but you put one
foot in front of the other in the words
of Princess Anna do the next right thing
yeah I like that do the next right thing
it's a song you should listen to it
you're cry Frozen from Frozen 2 I never
I never [__] with Frozen 2 Frozen 2
less than Frozen
one is there a two of anything that's
better than one in your opinion yes we
have this conversation all the time I
need to start a list you need to start a
list there are some twos that are better
than ones
two is better than
one that album that Boys Like Girls
album I don't know if they ever released
like another work of art besides that
one album because I only know that one
and it's like that black cover um where
like you know what was that song I used
to be love drunk but now I'm hung over
that album carried me for a great period
of my life it booed you it booed me I
need to see what other songs were on
that album because I need to go to
thesaurus.com for the word buoy oh my
God okay so I was talking to my friend
Abe and by the way all all most of the
people in my life who are you know I've
known for a really long time like listen
to the toast intermittently but so many
of them have been like I've listened to
every single episode this week like I
just needed it and I was talking to my
friend Abe yesterday about booing and he
was like by the way I meant to tell you
and he wasn't being like condescending
he's just like much smarter than me he
was like when you were asking Jackie for
like a definition of booing you said oh
like tethered and and he's like
tethering is like an antonym for booing
is a float and tethered is like down is
an anchor right similar concept but
complete ANTM no but also I was thinking
about it more after we had that
conversation on the show and like you
need to be booed when you're
drowning yes yes yes and we're
drowning yeah but when you're on land
like we all you know gravity we're two
feet on the ground
yeah so you actually need to be tethered
when you're like you
know when you're high up like when
you've lost a grip with with reality
right right but it's yes they are kind
of antonyms but you weren't saying they
were the same word you were saying I
know what you were saying he just
doesn't know you like I know you no he
doesn't know me like you know he doesn't
know tur's
brain um also just like a oh you go buoy
it means to make light or encourage so
I'm trying to see other words would be
like support raise prop
honestly buo is the right word yeah
could it be an uglier word buoy no and
like the way it's spelled
buing bu yeah like bu boo yeah
boo um the person who invented the word
buoy did not know how much we were about
to use it on the show no and how much
weight it would carry for the Jewish
people
yeah I'd like to shake his hand or her
him probably yeah probably wasn't
mentioned a long time ago the word right
around the time of the Tower of Babel no
and like it's a very Maritime esque word
and I just feel like back then even now
it's a male-dominated industry but
certainly back then sailing is for the
men 100% we've all Read It Happened One
Summer oh my God it's actually crazy how
like I don't think of fishing or boats
or like like the ocean without thinking
of that insane pornographic book like
it's insane like the imprint it left an
indelible mark on me it imprinted on you
it imprinted on me it's
insane honestly same honestly same it's
like really the smuttiest book I ever
read and like I I'm like good with that
being like my you know I don't need
nothing's ever going to top it I'm
always going to compare it to that and
like so every other smut book sucks okay
and by the way that was my intro to smut
and you recommended it to me and you
didn't even say I I wasn't sure I didn't
know smut from anything you were like
it's a romance book like it's cute they
like it's a little
runchy when I was reading this book and
this man stuck his thumb up her ass I
was like Jackie did not [__] read
this like there's no way on God green
diddly dally Earth that Jackie I'm like
i' I literally bought the wrong book on
Kindle Claudia I told you so many times
and I think I use the word spicy or porn
that was before like I really knew smut
Jackie that was the first it's a gateway
drug because every person it's a gateway
drug every single person I won't say
their names because they deserve their
privacy but like people we all know like
public figures I'm like the smut girl
and so whether it's for their book club
or they just like want to get into smut
or they're like taking you know like a
honeymoon or something they're like give
me smut recommendations I'm new to the
craft and I have like a list and St and
stuff and I always always always give
them It Happened One summer I said this
is a gateway drug to Mommy when you're
finished and I'll give you your
next your next feeding okay your next
dose no and they're right they're like
this is the best book ever no it's
seriously such a good book it needs to
be made into a movie and if you guys are
looking for some sort of like smut
breakdown I actually did one it was
humilating I did one on the patreon it's
like a 30 minute long video and podcast
episode where I go through every smut
book I've ever read give you like my
absolute must reads I give grades in
terms of like plot grades in terms terms
grades in terms of like spice um so
there's like a full breakdown honestly
like I did that for the girls like that
episode now lives forever and we can
always go back and reference it yeah
that's so funny that's honestly a great
episode no and when I was recording it
like I was deeply ashamed like you do it
for the girlies it was just like it was
awkward um yeah I could see it going
that
way so I think it's time you know it's
Friday want to get you guys on your way
yeah and I feel like without further Ado
yes before you do just a reminder to
everyone mostly you know anyone
listening particularly our Jewish
listeners to be extra just cautious and
Vigilant this weekend you never know I
don't want to like fear Monger but you
know people are talking about threats
the mongers are fearing full and I just
think we could nobody nobody ever
regretted being extra cautious yes but
also live your life life live it well
live it
proudly that's Jackie that's beautiful
thank you turo without further Ado About
turoo here are the fast five stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by the State Farm
personal price plan the State Farm
personal price plan helps you create a
plan that gives you options so you get
an affordable price and it comes with a
lot of benefits like the coverage you
want a policy that helps cover what's
important to you and an affordable price
made just for you because after all
isn't life better when you can
personalize your experience I mean
that's kind of one of the core tenants
here at toast University like life is so
personal comedy is so personal food is
so personal poetry is so personal
podcasting is so personal so think about
it like this what are your music plate
playlists podcast feeds social media
Scrolls all have in common well they're
a reflection of you so we all know my
social media is full of girls sharing
their OIC Journeys Jackie is full of
mommy content like even two girls who
are so similar even were're so different
and that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about it gives you
options to help personalize your
coverage so that you can protect what
you care about most at an affordable
price just for you so you can see more
of yourself in everything you love and
that's what's so fabulous about State
Farm cuz Jackie and I I feel like two
girls more similar have never existed
but when it comes to her insurance needs
I mean Jackie's a homeowner Jackie has a
Tesla she has two cars I barely have one
so like a good neighbor State Farm is
there call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary now let me do that
one more time like a good neighbor St
Farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan today's episode
is also brought to you by Thrive Market
our goto for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting everything online and then
quickly shipped to our door is a huge
timesaver Jackie as a Thrive Market
member tell everyone how you save money
on every single grocery order and some
of your favorite products Thrive Market
has the best prices and the best
products everything that they sell is
healthy so many organic products clean
products better for you products you
know we all want some chocolate but we
don't want all the chemicals associated
with it and if you're going to get
anything on Thrive Market you know it is
the best possible version of the food
that you want to eat I get all of my
pantry items from Thrive Market cooking
um what is it called like cooking tools
olive oil avocado oil oil sprays spices
everything from Thrive Market because
it's just the best version of whatever I
need to get we get all of our snacks for
the family kids included from Thrive
Market you can feel so good about giving
your kids food if it came from Thrive
market like it has just been amazing and
I don't have to Lug groceries from the
grocery store which is my favorite part
so whether you're looking for certified
gluten-free snacks low sugar
Alternatives non-toxic cleaning products
you can curate your own shopping
experience with the click of a button
that and trust that it's made with the
highest quality ingredients and sourcing
methods and when you join Thrive Market
you're also helping a family in need
with their one forone membership
matching program so join in on the
savings with Thrive market today and get
30% % off your first order plus a free
$60 gift go to thrivemarket.com
theeast for 30% off your first order
plus a fre $60 gift that's t r i v
market.com theeast thrivemarket.com
theeast great thank you so much what can
I say except y ugly so our first story
is our only like really War Story
officially you never know where combos
are going to take us but 700 notable
Hollywood figures sign an open letter in
support of Israel so Jackie what did you
read all the names on the list I did
well not all of them because a lot of
them are like behind the scenes people
one of them is your sister Claudia ashre
yeah uh I wasn't included on any of like
them you're not in the headlines no and
they're like click this link to see all
the other 700 the losers the 675 losers
that's me your girl is was there um but
yeah I was left out not to make you know
the war in Israel about me but I was
left off the list of Hollywood Elites
well that's so interesting because I saw
that there was this letter and I really
wanted to see everyone who was on it but
then I kept seeing these articles
written about it where they plucked out
you know the famous people the need to
know the need to know there's not that
many but it's worth knowing who they are
so galot Jerry Seinfeld Jam Lee Curtis
and Chris Pine are among the Sines who
condemned the Palestinian terrorist
group hamas's attack saying this is
Terrorism this is evil very
unequivocally standing with Israel Mayim
biik also signed leab striver shriber
Amy Schumer and Michael Douglas you know
the usuals no there's like not there's
two surprising people on this list and
there should be way more the first is
Chris Pine that's my king right there
like anything he needs I'll be there for
him would and he just like busted out of
the Chris list because now he's like the
good Chris he's different than all of
the Chris's and the other who wasn't
fcked from the headline but you know I
was like so nosy I went and read the
whole list Bella Thorne oh my God I saw
Bella Thorn's Instagram yesterday I
followed her yesterday girly is crushing
it yeah I'm I was surprised I feel like
if you don't really want to make a
statement on social media which you know
is understandable I feel like signing
this letter amongst like a bunch of your
peers is actually like a pretty good way
to take a stand without I guess opening
yourself up to backlash yeah and so I
surprised that more people didn't um use
this as like a almost like a like look
I'm here bye I'm yeah yeah yeah like
check the box yeah you don't because you
not everyone needs to post everything on
social media as we discussed there are a
lot of celebrities who like I don't I
don't even know if they have Instagram
require like Adam Sandler we were saying
um so yeah this is a good way to you
know the get in the game without mucking
up your highly curated social media feed
that's run by an agency and you don't
even have the password s too right so I
was surprised it wasn't more fabulous
yeah so here are some other names that
we know Deborah it's a lot of like big
time directors producers behind the
scenes people who we don't know but
there are other notable names Deborah
Messing Ryan
murrey Yes Zachary
Levi Shazam Shazam the thing is Zachary
Levi and Zachary Quinto are the same
exact people to me and they're both
industry plans wait I just found out
something crazy hm [__] I need to
remember it hold on okay so should I
hold off on continuing yes
because hold
on no maybe it's not Zachary Levi hold
on maybe it's Zachary
Quinto wait I I I I found something out
and I can't remember I feel like it was
one of the zachar had like a like
another famous person is their sister
like I it was great was it maybe it was
Quinto does anybody know what I'm
talking about no it wasn't Quinto it
wasn't
Quinto okay I think
maybe yes oh no no no okay I don't know
what I'm talking about let me know when
you're done with this I'm done by the
way does anybody else like did anybody
else find something out like Hollywood
sibling related recently with a man
named Zachary or does anybody have any
idea what I'm talking about I found it
out and I was like no
way no maybe a sibling but not a
Zachary okay I feel like I was on the
phone with you when I found it
out I feel like we're not going to be
able to grasp this I have no DET to far
away I have no no details to like
finding we're not getting warmer no I
like we're never going to find out what
what I'm thinking no we will in a few
weeks no I don't even I think like
seriously it's one of those things that
entered my brain never to return again
okay let me continue
deor messing Ryan Murphy Zachary Levi
Sharon Osborne M George Lopez who's
going to clean your toilet Donald Trump
Claudia that's buoying me that's I
watched that video last night I made
Zach watch it last night because I was
rolling around on the bed when you sent
me this meme of of Kelly Osborne on a
golden toilet I was rawle ma rawful Ming
and Zach like didn't didn't know what I
was talking about so I was like okay you
have to watch this clip and then you
have to look at this accompanying meme
by the way the okay so I watched the
clip again last night and the craziest
thing about the clip is right before
Kelly says that thing Rosie Perez is
saying how just like racist remarks are
not helpful to the rhetoric like at all
and Kelly's like I agree and think about
this who's gonna clean your toilet like
says the most [__] racist thing right
after Rosie Perez was like racist and
like you know outlandish remarks like
are not moving the needle here yeah and
you just could tell like Kelly like had
that Zinger in her head so she probably
wasn't even listening to the comment
before her cuz she was waiting to say
her thing and when she said it like it's
like Mug Drop Like and and then she's
like oh no oh no instead it's like
crickets she's like no like that come on
like how else could somebody receive
that like it was insane honestly that
clip can and should be studied by a team
of experts it's it's human nature at its
worst oh my goodness
continuing the list Diane
Warren Howe
Mand Julia
Edelman and then everyone else I don't
know so they're like behind the scenes
Peeps and Claudia a like I like I was on
the list I swear I believe that you were
on the list like if you want to go and
here's the whole I made it to the whole
letter I'm sure there are people on this
list that I would actually find
interesting it goes alphabetical at the
end sure it does no it does like I
really should have led with my um middle
name because I'm all the way at the
bottom with
as Emanuel
chei she should have been in the
headlines she should have been in the
headlines okay I can scan this
later anyways so that was news but do
you see me oh let me use the search bar
yep comedian and podcast
host Josh
peek there's Chris Pine Billy
Porter oh by the way why in the article
why isn't he in the article I just TNN
hasn't posted a statement but I want
everyone to know TNN stands firmly with
Israel yeah I was worried like where
does the network stand
yeah just wanted to clear up that sort
of
Scandal okay I'll let you know if I see
anyone else but we're going to move on
from this anyways just thought that was
interesant thank you to these 700 people
um and I also think like if you don't
know like what to do pr- wise like that
would have been a good way to to mark
yourself as safe from from I don't know
from the toast from us we've become
those people I I really need to stop
like I do but I I can't like I'm so in
it it's just because we give these
people so much time and energy on our
show I feel like if we didn't do the
show like I I don't know how to what
degree I would care what celebrities are
doing but like I just need to know like
who we are going to continue to support
if they don't support us like existing
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um our next story just some tea from the
J sisters Sophie
Turner oh yeah Sophie Turner unfollows
prianka Chopra on Instagram amid her
divorce with Joe Jonas so there's drama
among the Jay sisters as Sophie has
unfollowed Nick's wife Priyanka on
Instagram amid her divorce from Joe
however she continues to follow Nick
Kevin and his wife uh Danielle as well
as her EST strange husband Joe so this
this is T this is like I've been waiting
to unfollow you or this is like she's
not liking how Priyanka is behaving in
the divorce ooh t hot in the words of
Sophie Turner and that's the T and
that's the I miss when she used to do
that that was cute yeah it was um I feel
like this is a story like we would have
started hearing about like if there was
beef between the J sisters like long
withstanding this is something that
would have gotten leaked like that cuz
that's so interesting like the two
famous wives not if it wasn't ever a
blowup and more so like an
undercurrent you know maybe yeah if they
had like a screaming match that one of
the handlers would have leaked it but if
they just never liked each
other they spend a lot of time
together like on tour with the guys like
they're like a tightened
family so it's that's shocking I had so
seen this headline and I just assumed
she unfollowed all of them so I was like
they're just making a thing out of
Priyanka but no to to single single
single her out I can't talk anymore to
single her out I need to
know yeah I don't I don't know if we'll
ever know but this is this is an
interesting
nugget it
is and so do with that information what
you will I will do with that information
what I will
are you ready for our next story some
more sibling drama mhm Noah Cyrus is
calling out her sister Miley for shady
interview saying the disrespect so Noah
Cyrus posted a comment like on a Tik Tok
video of Miley on Joe Rogan where Miley
is talking about her little sis Noah and
Noah commented the disrespect in this
video dot dot dot so the qu clip in
question showed Miley chatting with Joe
Rogan about her siblings on his show in
September 2020 um he asked Miley whether
Noah's experience growing up in her
Shadow had deterred her from chasing a
career in Hollywood and Miley said you
either go one way or the other and she
noted that her sister like wants that
life in the spotlight she said she's got
a record out that I love called the end
of everything and it's the most
depressing EP you'll ever listen to
she's 20 years old she's emo she's like
an emo kid and Joe asked if she was emo
cuz she grew up on the road with Miley
and Miley was like yeah that's what it
is she has a song where she's like
my sister's like sunshine it'll follow
her wherever she goes but I'm more like
a raincloud you know she has this idea
of Miley um to which Joe commented that
Noah should perhaps go to a doctor and
Miley said she is we all go to the
doctor a lot we have a doctor on
salary um okay I feel
like I I don't think this is the case
but I do think some could interpret that
comment as like sister like I would
leave a comment like that on Margo's Tik
Tok like the disrespect of this video um
but they're talking about like deeply
like personal things of Noah when it's
an interview for Miley um but why
comment on it 3 years later maybe I mean
those interviews are long I doubt she
watched the whole
thing you know but I feel like that
would have like been like a a pull quote
and a headline from the interview when
it when it was released at the time I
don't I don't
know I feel like a lot of people don't
watch the whole thing and so the one
person who watches it they probably got
a different you know headline and then
every single news organization like
writes the exact same story I could see
how a comment like this could just like
slide out under the radar cuz really
there's nothing here she said she's an
emo kid her EP is depressing like if you
listen to her music you know that
there's that was her aesthetic for a
while it I feel like it still is her
aesthetic maybe she's talking about Joe
Rogan being disrespectful cuz he's
saying like she needs to go to the
doctor oh oh oh I guess you're right
she's not pointing who is being
disrespectful like it could be Joe yeah
cuz I didn't think Miley was being so
disrespectful she said she has an
amazing EP out it's just depress in but
like I feel like that's Noah's you know
Vibe like that's not a shock to hear
that but that's not like a a negative
thing to say like a critique yeah that's
just an obvious thing to say but I also
agree like I could see you commenting
this on someone's video I don't know if
they're close enough that they like you
know make barbs like that
but it could be a nothing burger or it
could be a something Burger but context
is important because Tish just got
married to the guy from prison break
okay Miley was there Brandy was there I
don't believe Noah was there like I
think the family is experiencing some
sort of braus
mhm and this just kind of furthers my
thoughts on
that yeah in which case that's just like
not where you go with your anger towards
your family is the comment section of a
Tik Tok no you should never go there
with anything let alone like dirty
laundry yeah um do you think like when
we were growing up if I had been cast in
Hannah Montana and like become this
major major major super well I'm younger
than you so I guess okay if you if you
had like gone on to become like a star
of like a huge franchise like how would
that have impacted
me I think I would have been like
insanely
jealous it depends on the person you
would have been if you like wanted to
get into the industry but on the other
hand like you would have had a foot in
the industry think of like who I was as
a kid like attention seeking loud
singing dancing like yeah I would have
been jealous like filled with
rage
yeah I don't think
so maybe jealous but not filled with
rage like you could be jealous of
someone or like you know yes want that
same thing that they have without being
like bad you know while also being happy
for them yeah yeah but also like we're
the type of family where it's like oh
Jackie got a show write a role for
Claudia Margot and Olivia right her
little sister wants to be an actress too
do like I have to imagine if Noah was
like really into it at the time they
were bringing on everyone like there was
literally not a single person wasn't on
an episode of Hannah Montana right I
feel
like she was involved in some way but
she was also really young really young
cuz Miley was really young yeah no
Miley's done everything for her yeah
like seriously like let's get a grip
Let's Get a
Grip it's also really crazy like how
fake
famous well actually is it crazy think
of nepo babies who out neppo their
parent you know like Miley is more
famous we weren't really alive for like
Billy Ray Cyrus's Peak but I I know he
was a on- hit wonder it happens
sometimes that the nepo baby super Kelly
Bieber yeah I would say gwenneth paltro
outo her mother
yeah
um but then there's nepo like kids who
aren't from like famous parents but
they're from like very well-connected
rich parents which is different like
Jonah Hill ambr right no but she she'll
never out nepo JJ abrs like he's I just
saw a headline about them today in
People magazine that's why she was top
of mine she sings right she does I
actually saw a tweet about her that went
viral because like it was a list she
submitted a bunch of her music and and
from this year for different Grammys and
so it was just a list like here's what
Gracie Abrams put up for consideration
and it was like her album album of the
year and it was just like this like it
was just a lot of her music in like
enormous categories and people were
tweeting like this is
crazy like I I I I know one song I think
Parton me wants to walk away till you
really listen and honestly I actually
feel like she doesn't even sing that
hold
on oh it is Gracey abrs okay I was right
I just feel like there's so many like
young teeny bopper girls who look like
Gracie Abrams and sing like Gracie like
mine I I know you don't know her but
like she had and it's over and you're
driving me home like tell me that's not
Gracie Abrams no there are a lot of them
right now but the cream will rise and
and they will sort through itself soon
Gracie Abrams core is a thing yeah but
is it even Gracie who started it that's
a great question I feel like it's not I
feel like it was like free freey
Bridgers it's like Olivia Rodrigo core
no no it's not cuz these like don't make
pop music it's like it's literally
depressed girl
like no she's emo this is different this
is just like
Poetic emotional teenage girly music
that can only be listened to in the car
you're literally describing Olivia
Rodrigo though she did transcend poetic
like you pop your [__] to Olivia
Rodrigo yeah but think of like driver's
license that was just her dver was very
Gracie Abrams coded right so I feel like
she started it she's branched out but
people are doing the driver's license
bit wait and speaking of like reading
from their Diaries and singing it do you
know the song Lacy on Olivia Rodrigo's
album no it's just about like a girl
named Lacy who like Olivia R go is so
jealous of like I want to be Lacy Lacy
oh
Lacy Have I Told You
Lately like I'm just you're beautiful
and I want to be you and I hate you and
there's like a big conspiracy theory
that Lacy is Gracie Abrams graci Gracie
Lacy so there is no I there could be
something there and then like Gracie
Abrams was opening for Taylor and like
honestly in another world that should
have been Olivia Rodrigo yeah yeah our
next story is the bit of content news
that I hope buoys me is it the bit of
content news that you ho buoys you
that's brought to you by better help yes
thank God well have you ever felt like
your brain is getting in its own way you
know you just can't can't help yourself
like you know what you should do you
know what's good for you but you just
physically cannot do it therapy helps
you figure out what's holding you back
so you can work for yourself instead of
against yourself if you've ever you know
been thinking about giving therapy a try
you find it kind of intimidating highly
recommend better help better help is
done entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule how it works is you'll fill out
a questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist at any time for no additional
charge so it being done entirely online
means that you can communicate with your
therapist in whatever medium makes you
feel less awkward so you can text you
can phone call you can video call um and
a huge part of therapy is you know
sometimes it takes two or three
therapists to you feel like you found
the right match for you and in person
that can be extremely awkward with
better help it's so easy to switch it's
not awkward at all like they totally get
it and you can switch until you find
someone who you feel really comfortable
with so make your bra your friend with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com toast to
get 10% off your first month of
betterhelp that's betterhelp
hp.com toast betterhelp.com
toast if you're experiencing I mean the
world around is just like difficult
enough there's never a bad time to just
start taking care of yourself and if you
take care of a lot of people in your
life and you find yourself being thrown
to the Wayside take care of yourself
with better help today's episode is also
brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one website PL platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place all on your own
terms it's 2023 like girl you need a
website and it can't be janky and weird
and you know nobody not everyone has
like a million dollars to spend on a
fancy computer science team of Engineers
and that's where square space comes in
if you want to get a website up off the
ground whether you have like a side
business or you work in e-commerce
whatever your reason reasoning is you're
a photographer who wants to Showcase a
stunning portfolio online whatever your
reasoning is for needing a website
Squarespace has the template for you
they will get you up and running and
they have all these different features
that are going to make your website work
best for you so an asset Library you can
upload organize and access all your
content on Squarespace websites you're
able to manage all your files from one
Central Hub and use them across the
platform you can sell custom merch
create a passive income stream that
engages your audience and scales your
brand of course e-commerce you can
create an online store with square space
and their flexible website templates are
fabulous and you can get started with
one of them today with designs for every
category and use case and customiz it's
totally customizable you can update your
content and add features to fit your
unique unique needs so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast and you'll save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain that's squarespace.com
toast Claudia while you've been reading
the ads I've been going through the list
to see if there were any more notable
names and I have a name for you that's
going to send you into another
Stratosphere okay should we should we do
guess who no you couldn't if you tried
okay Joyce
Gerard no yeah sign the letter iconic
one season Wonder iconic one season
Wiccan Wonder no that's not Wiccan
that's Carlton jabia oh you're thinking
of Joyce who uh I think she was a
pageant Queen Ry did not get along yeah
yeah yeah no I conflated her with
Carlton because they came on for one
season together and then they left I
actually Carlton was two seasons but I I
agree they're they're the same era of
housewife history yes also Helen Miran
is on the
list Queen why wasn't she in the
headline I don't know there's a few
names that like didn't make the headline
that I think AJ McLean from the
Backstreet Boys Back Street Boys greater
than in sync by the way Helen Miran is
not tracking like if you're an active
like if you're you're like a Jewish
person you know Helen mir's a queen she
just um she just played Golda Golda
Mayer in the movie Golda Golda Mayer Who
was the first female prime minister of
Israel um I Heard the movie with Fab I
haven't seen it and she's in women woman
in Gold she does like a lot of work to
further Jewish causes woman in Gold I
need to see that oh my God Claudia you
need to see it I know how have you not
seen it because like for a very long
time anything that was even remotely
intellectually stimulating or historical
was not my cup of tea but I'm growing
Jackie I'm evolving I'm doing better you
are you're obsessed now obsessed even
though I have not been able to read what
you know who sign the letter who Eliza
schlinger okay she's Jewish no I know
but that's just worth noting it is worth
noting like when Jews do the bare
minimum yeah no because we were hard on
her about that Joe Rogan interview that
was oh we were we didn't like like we
thought that episode was cringe we
didn't enjoy it but you know what
that's my queen right there that's my
queen right there okay let's get into
our fifth and final story which you're
actually not going to care about but me
and a cult following that's kind of
that's kind of the theme of this week
like stories nobody cares about no no no
that's no no no that's not why you're
not going to care you're not going to
care because this is a show with a cult
following that you're not a part of but
that I happened to watch when it was on
and I happen to be re-watching okay and
that's
Community yeah no never got into it
Olivia's [__] obsessed she is sorry
Parenthood I get confused with like
onewed TV shows that are 30 minutes long
no so Community fans they're Mighty
Community is actually going to be made
into a movie Zach and I are re-watching
Community right now it's like what we
watch at night while we're waiting for
um like Charlie to go to sleep for the
night and it is so that's Joel male
right Joel male yeah at the community
college yeah CL you been started it once
like what episode and I it wasn't for me
Claudia it's for you you absolutely need
to watch it it's literally so funny Joel
male though was on Mark Marin's WTF
podcast and he was weighing in on Chevy
Chase's recent disc of community I'm
sorry he was weighing in on who's Chevy
Chase
Chevy yeah his name spelled Chevy it's
Chevy okay well Chevrolet has co-opted
the name Chevy Chase I'm
obsessed don't make fun of me from
pronunciations because I learned it by
reading it no and it's confusing like a
Chevy is a car so but Chevy right so
Chevy Chase recently like kind of
slammed sorry I I can't I like keep
interrupting you is Chevy Chase in the
show yes oh okay cadd Shack Chevy Chase
icon he's a big part of the show it's
well it's an ensemble cast it's really
Joel Mel's show but everyone else is
pretty equal he had a really um like
funny character role but he actually
said
um that Community wasn't funny enough
for him ultimately he said I felt a
little bit constrained everybody had
their bits and I thought they were all
good it just wasn't hard-hitting enough
for me when asked about his character
millionaire Pierce Hawthorne Chevy added
I didn't mind the character I just felt
that it was I was I felt happier being
alone I just didn't want to be
surrounded by that table every day with
those people it was too much um so Joe
male was just on WTF podcast and he was
like I mean we weren't sentenced to that
show it was like all right you could
have left if you really wanted that yeah
and he said the feeling Mutual Bud he
stopped hurting my feelings in 2009
worth noting that Chevy Chase was fired
for Community for using a racial slur in
what year was that oh my God T and
Donald Glover AKA
childish got his start on community and
he has spoken about Chevy Chase being
like disrespectful and racist towards
him oh my God CH Chevy Chase's character
Pierce Hawthorne is like an old racist
yeah maybe he was me
acting literally oh my God wait that's
crazy if this show like was more popular
like people like this would have been a
bigger story I feel like it's probably
just like within the the
community yes but it has such a crazy
Following the show Community like it's
even coming back for a
movie on peacock give it another chance
like I remember just Ben me and Ben were
like maybe you were talking about it
like years ago so we started it I was
like me you've got to give it a few
episodes cuz I don't remember like the
beginning you got to let them like set
the table but I have had some serious
belly laughs since we've been rewatching
it like I'm sorry the dean of the school
his name is Dean like
it's it's so funny well I'm currently
belly laughing to the nanny like I can't
think about anything till I'm done with
the nanny I didn't realize how many
episodes of The Nanny I'd actually never
seen even though like you said that
about suits or whatever you were
watching you said we watch Love Island
UK season 5 and you didn't I did say
that well in my defense I never finished
suits because we got so into the nanny
and like suits everybody says like after
season 6 it goes downhill but like my
God after season 6 does it go downhill I
can't believe I felt like maybe I'm
watching a show like at the time that
maybe went on strike and they hired some
like people off the street to write the
show because it's the dumbest [__] like
I'm in shock I'm like okay if anybody
knows what I'm talking about like the
Donna let me tell you this me and Ben
were talking about on an episode that he
co-hosted with
me um so Donna is the redheaded
secretary who like runs the firm like
she's knows everything about everyone y
y and this guy and like the IT
department was like I've been working on
this project for years and Donna it's
time I finally show it to you and he
created basically like an Alexa but it's
called The
Donna and they're taking it to Market
because it's like this it's the digital
secretary that everyone in the law
industry needs and they go to see
investors and they're like Donna's like
going to quit the firm because like the
Donna is taking off me and Ben were
looking at each other we're like is this
a spoof and it like spanned over a few
episodes The Donna the Donna is Megan
marle still on the the show yeah of
course I think she oh did she leave at
one point because she no no no Harry was
after suits no during suits at the very
end it was at the very end I don't know
actually she left and then the show
ended well I I want to say like she's an
amazing part of the show but the show
like isn't predicated on her if any I
don't know if there's anyone there's so
many good characters I don't know if
there's anyone who who if they left the
show would have had to end it's a it's a
true ensemble cast no but I don't know
if it it ended because of her but like I
think she left before it was over
because she was on her way to being a
princess
well I don't know cuz I haven't gotten
there okay keep me posted I probably
won't because like I have no interest to
go back and watch that's a good way to
end a show instead of being depressed
that you finished all the episodes and
it's over and like you go into like a
show hangover like instead let it just
suck and you choose not to watch anymore
CU then it never ends lost like one of
the most miserable experiences of my
life was finishing lost that's like Glee
I don't think I ever watched last season
and so like to me it's I never had to
experience that sadness of it being over
Jackie 100% I have re-watched Glee maybe
three or four times and I watched it
live when it was airing and I have never
ever seen the final season yeah every
time I rewatch it you have the same
cycle of like emotions like I'm kind of
getting over this this show is stupid oh
I forgot to keep watching yeah yeah it
is good actually it's nice but it's also
really nice when like a show ends
perfect perfectly shits Creek like you
don't feel like drawn out you miss it
like that's they always say it's like a
privilege to be able to end your own
show and there's still like a huge
audience yeah
yeah okay well those were the fast five
stories I feel as though you did need to
know them as you had let's talk about
next week let's talk about next week
because very much up in the air West
Coast tury so Monday's episode of next
week will be an audio only because I am
traveling that day and I'm speaking on a
panel too
Tuesday I am recording with someone in
Los Angeles should I say who like it's
confirmed sure Jackie Shimmel she's
never been on the toast and I love her
so exciting and honestly it'll be a
Jackson Claude like Jackson Claude no
and like I think I'm like funny and mean
and sharp like she's gonna blow me out
of the water like I'm actually afraid
can't wait Wednesday is what I'm going
to La for so Jackie will be holding down
the fort with an episode um
TBD with who I've got some things
Brewing Thursday I have Heather McDonald
my other Queen and Friday I'm still
working on I'm trying to nail an
interview can't wait this is very
exciting we love La tury so bear with us
for next week love LA and just know the
episodes that I'm recording with people
in La I will be on Easter uh western
western what's it called Pacific West
Coast Pacific time so for the Pacific
coast girly
you're fine but the New York Early the
episodes are delayed when I'm in La so
just keep that in mind for your schedule
and your routine okay well thank you so
much tury we look forward to seeing you
on the west coast and what you have in
store for us I got a pack scrub my spray
tan off get a new spray tan like you
know the whole like that's what I'm
doing this weekend like before the big
the big trip
great well we'll see you next week
everyone keep your heads up stay safe
try and find some pockets of Peace but
we also you know we can't be ignorant to
what's going on so it's a balance of
that thank you guys so much for all the
positive feedback this week you are
booing us legitimately you are oh my God
I opened a message that made me
hysterically
cry yesterday like The Toasters are just
so nice like for real and they always
know what to say no and she was just
like I see what you're doing and like I
can't donate much but like I'm a very
skilled website developer if any any
Jewish organizations need like any sort
of like website help like just offering
anything she could offer and like her
her time and her experience like I was
so moved by it and I sent her
information around and I just messaged
her I was like this was so like I was
just so moved by this thank you so much
yeah no everybody is contributing so
much and like we've been sharing so many
wonderful organizations that you can
donate to and like The Toasters are just
are donating and it's so it's so nice to
see it does not go unnoticed and we know
that we're sharing a lot of links and
and every time we share like an if it's
like a organ like a small org and we
know the person they're like oh my God
they're so shook by the response that
they get and it's like just you guys
continuing to donate and give and it's
amazing and like seriously I I will
never forget like the kindness and
generosity and just like the empathy of
our community this week and just like
giving us space and being like you don't
have to record an episode like just true
understanding and true allyship and I'm
deeply deeply moved and comforted by it
yeah me too and we will not forget it so
thank you so much for listening to the
toast of Millay Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes Stitch Republic radio I Radio
cast box all the places we listen to
podcast find us see five star I bet a
beautiful standing and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing
weekend love you dearly
I'm love you bye